21st year we're gonna change and shift
gears a little bit here to a different
author who is at the Book Fair and who
is joining us he is Brian Greene the
author of the elegant universe and his
newest book is called the fabric of the
cosmos he joins us in the room and we
will start talking various hi I'm mr.
green how are you first of all thanks ru
first of all let me ask you to explain
the type of writing that you do my books
are aimed at a general audience that has
some hunger some urge to know how the
universe works but hasn't gone to
graduate school so it doesn't know
mathematics at the graduate level or
even the undergraduate level but still
wants to know what current cutting-edge
science is telling us about the universe
so the books take away the math take
away the technical details and
communicate cutting-edge science using
analogies and stories and metaphors that
allow you to grasp at a visceral level
what's going on now you are a physicist
correct yes I am and when you decide
when did you decide to start writing for
a general public
oh I decided around 1996 or so after I
gave a couple of lectures to general
audiences and found that there was this
great energy and enthusiasm to know what
was going on but there wasn't that much
to point people towards to read further
so I decided to give a shot and that
gave rise to the elegant universe my
first book and your second book the
fabric of the cosmos deals won it with
with time give us a little bit of
background on what you're talking about
what are the questions that we would
that we are asking about time well the
deep questions about time are does time
have a beginning will time have an end
is time a real feature of the universe
or is it something that we impose on the
universe to organize our experience in
our perceptions does time have a
direction is past really different from
future can that distinction if it exists
be found within the laws of physics
these are the kinds of questions about
time that we have
struggling with for a very long time and
in my second book the fabric of the
cosmos I try to give a sense of where
we've gotten after thinking about these
deep questions about time for 300 years
where are we today
and where are we today well we've made a
lot of progress if you go back and look
at what Newton told us about time he
said time is what you think it is time
elapses in equal intervals for everybody
that is your watch ticks off the same
rate as mine does regardless of where we
are or what we're doing but then we've
learned from Einstein in 1905 that that
is not how time behaves we learn that if
you and I are moving relative to each
other our watches take off time at
different rates
we learn that if I am near the edge of a
black hole my watch will take off much
more slowly than yours will time is in
the eye of the beholder now that was a
hundred years ago since then we have
learned a lot more about time when we
thought about it how it interfaces with
a field called quantum physics the
physics of the very small and today I
think we're poised on the revolution of
a new way of thinking about time and
space as well in which we'll learn that
they're not even fundamental well learn
that space and time are definitely part
of physics as we formulate it but that
at rock-bottom they are not fundamental
ideas there's something deeper that they
emerge from and the real prize is going
to go to whoever can figure out what the
true underlying ingredients that give
rise to space and time actually are
we're trying to find the atoms if you
will of space and time themselves for a
public policy network like ours can you
take that one step forward and try to
match the kind of work that's being done
in this area with a public policy debate
is there any intersection well there is
because all of the scientific work that
we're involved with has to be funded and
of course their limited funds what do
you spend your money on so for instance
we were building
machine and Texas called the
superconducting supercollider in the
early 1990s and that was a meant to be a
huge atom smasher huge tunnel in which
particles would slam together at high
energies recreating events unseen since
the Big Bang and that was a very
expensive undertaking and it was
ultimately cancelled because budgetary
constraints wouldn't allow it to go
forward this was a big blow to science
so there you see that the intersection
of the work that we're doing with public
policy can have a great impact on the
rate of progress Brian Green is our
guest and first call from him is from
Waukegan Illinois
hello Waukegan yes my call was for the
other gentleman I'm sorry okay we'll go
on then Thank You San Diego hello hi
thank you so much calling from San Diego
and I was just thinking in the matters
of public policy if you could interest
the adventure capital guy into some
aspect of what you're doing believe me
the money will show if you so if you
position it they will come in regard and
I'm sorry also if you could just put
tasty morsels of your book on a website
so the rest of us could benefit yes I
called earlier in regard to the earlier
off there it's the same thing I have a
website called San Diego judges com
which which went on pretty much like
courtroom 302 but the website keeps
everyone on the same page so to speak or
at least makes the knowledge available
so would you consider putting some of
your stuff on a website that's the whole
book of course just a little morsel mr.
green sure in fact there are there are
websites that do have a lot of the
current thinking on some of the
questions that we've been discussing
there's wws super string theory calm if
you go there you can find a whole lot of
information along the lines of what
we're discussing here my book itself you
won't actually find on any website and
not that I have anything against that
it's just it takes a lot of effort to
put it out there and where someone
willing to help me I don't know how to
actually put things on webpages but I'd
be more than happy to have tidbits
the cutting-edge ideas about space and
time to be out there more available
absolutely do you think that some of us
who have a little hard time
understanding your world will think it's
interesting that you don't know much
about webpages well you know I'm a
theorist and so everything that I do is
really calculations on a piece of paper
and I think the younger theorists who
are in fact some of them are my students
and postdocs they certainly do know how
to put things on webpage and that's part
of the reason why I don't because I
always give it over to them to do it
that's a danger of being an older person
in the field so to speak at the advanced
age of you're asking my age yes oh you
know somewhere in the 40s yeah let's go
next to this San Diego's not there let's
go to the East Chester East Chester New
York is that right yes go ahead all
right first degree green I just have a
quick scenario for you if you consider a
reflective cavity encasing a charged
particle that's oscillating with simple
harmonic motion and you say that that
charge of that oscillating charge will
be radiating electromagnetic waves and
if you consider that those
electromagnetic waves will uniformly
distribute themselves throughout the
cavity and induced impulses back on the
charged particle and eventually the
system would reach a sort of classical
type of ground state what do you think
about the possibility of deriving some
of the fundamental aspects of quantum
mechanics from this sort or any sort of
general quantum mechanical hidden
variable approach thank you
Wow could you translate that for us
first professor well actually I was
gonna I was gonna ask the question if he
could repeat before no no that's okay
the questioner seems to have mixed a few
ideas together and I won't belabor some
of the things that I'm having difficulty
understanding and why they're being
mixed but the bottom-line question was
can we think about quantum mechanics
from a so-called hidden variable point
of view and this is an idea that was
very interesting to ienai himself in the
1920s and 1930s
he in fact wrote one of the early papers
on quantum physics in 1905 but then
didn't really like where the field went
in the years that followed and was
trying to find alternative ways of
thinking about the physics of very small
things that's what quantum mechanics is
and as of today all of those
alternatives don't seem to match the
data the way the conventional approach
does so the bottom line answer to the
question would be we still are adhering
to the conventional description of
quantum physics who knows where things
will go in the future but that's where
we are as of today the earlier caller
had brought up whether there might be
some venture capitalists out there who
who might be able to fund the work it
does that happen private private work in
this area of private financing well
private money is very important to us
although much of our funding does come
from the government the government
funding though is precarious at times so
many of us are seeking private money
that would give us endowments that we
could rely upon without any possibility
of the money going away the hard thing
about attracting private money is we're
not producing a product we're not
producing something that can be marketed
and that of course is usually important
to venture capitalists the private funds
that we seek are usually more of
philanthropic money people who want to
support very basic research that in
years to come may have a profound impact
on the way we live our lives but as if
today is really in the very research
stage we're not really developing
anything that can be put out there in
the market you caused quite a scene with
your earlier book the elegant universe
you were nominated for a Pulitzer was
that correct no that's correct finalists
for a Pulitzer Prize I know
finalists for a Pulitzer and I guess
what I'm saying is in just in terms of
the string theory that's something like
the string theory became a part of the
lexicon of people who may not have ever
been involved or thought a whole lot
about science where are we at with the
string theory now well a string theory
is what we hope to be the unified theory
that Albert Einstein was looking for for
the last thirty years of his life
and it purports to describe all the
forces of nature and all of matter in
one framework and that's a very big goal
and we've been working on it for 30
years tremendous progress wonderful and
exciting ideas have emerged from those
studies but we have a ways to go and the
most important thing that we've yet to
achieve is experimental evidence that
these ideas are correct our hope is that
in the next few years a machine that's
not being built on American soil but in
Geneva Switzerland a machine that's
called the Large Hadron Collider that
machine at least has the chance of
testing some of the ideas of string
theory it's not a certainty that it will
it's a long shot but at least it's
possible at in the near future we may
get some experimental input telling us
that these ideas are on the right track
that is what we all are crossing our
fingers about and that's the most
exciting thing on the horizon today and
for lay audience what could be the
impact of proving the string theory not
much from the point of view of everyday
life but if you were to have asked me in
the 1920s what would be the impact of
quantum physics I think if I was an
honest scientist at that time I would
have told you not much you know we're
dealing with molecules and atoms they're
so small so far removed from everyday
life that quantum physics won't really
have an impact but today 80 years later
your cell phone your personal computer
all manner of medical equipment and
technology everything that relies upon
an integrated circuit and they are
everywhere in our culture in our society
all of that relies upon quantum
mechanics which is just to say that you
can't really know where basic research
is going to lead so you ask me today
where will string theory take us if it's
proven right from that point of view I
don't know but five hundred years from
now a thousand years from now if string
theory is corrected to have a major
impact on the way we lead our lives for
someone like me though that's really not
the goal our goal is to understand the
deep questions how the universe began
the questions about time that we started
off with does time have a beginning
what is time those are the kinds of
questions that we may be able to answer
if string theory is correct
that's what motivating
and a whole generation of scientists
around the globe next call for Brian
Greene is Newark California hi it's
going to be obvious that I I don't know
anything about physics but I am curious
what preceded the big day you know and
if the Big Bang was a beginning to me
that implies that there had to be
something before it and what was that
and if our universe endless are we you
know are we contained within something
larger or is there something beyond what
we conceive of as as the universe mr.
green yeah those are two great questions
was there something before the Big Bang
and the quick answer is we don't know
but let me just flesh that a little bit
it could be that the Big Bang was the
very beginning of time that there was no
notion of time before the Big Bang and
therefore talking about the word before
doesn't even make any sense it's as if
you're walking on the surface of the
earth and you ask somebody which way is
north and they point you north you ask
somebody else a little while later which
way is north they point you're north
again when you get to the North Pole and
you say how do I go further north they
look at you kind of strange and say you
can't go further north the North Pole is
where North begins it could similarly be
that you can imagine looking back in
time looking further back in time but
you get to the Big Bang itself you may
not be able to go further back in time
in much the same way as you can't go
further north than the North Pole so the
Big Bang might be where time itself
began now from the point of view of
science today we don't know that that's
correct
we are struggling to figure out maybe
there is a realm before the Big Bang
where there is time or some other notion
that evolves into time at the onset of
the Big Bang itself great questions were
still struggling but in terms of is
there something beyond the universe that
we currently see again we don't know but
current theories of cosmology a theory
known as inflationary cosmology strongly
suggests strongly suggest that what we
see is a tiny little part of a much
grander
Osmos what we have access to is like a
single grain of sand on a huge beach
filled with other grains of sand which
in the metaphor would be other universes
other regions of space that are beyond
our ability to see today so it's very
possible that what we have long thought
to be the universe the 14 billion years
of evolution that we have access to with
our telescopes that maybe a tiny
fraction of a much grander cosmos toledo
ohio your next go ahead yeah thanks a
lot quick comp come and thank God for
c-span I mean it's the only channel
worth watching for news and current
affairs like mr. green here I mean dear
God I mean can't even see a man like
that on CNN for crying out loud so well
I guess my previous caller asked my
questions for me I mean my essentially
my question was you know is there any
limit to the university are there any
boundaries I mean where exactly are we
floating and just a quick other question
what was so great about Einstein I mean
even now today every you know scientist
or whatever I hear always refers back to
Einstein what exactly made him so great
thanks a lot sure well it's very natural
when you think about the universe to
imagine that it has edges because every
object that we look at always has some
finite extent and some boundary to it
could it be the case with the universe
we don't think so if the universe had an
edge you'd imagine going up to the edge
and punching through what would be on
the other side not the universe some
other kind of universe so most of us
believe that the universe doesn't have
boundaries or edges either it goes on
forever or like the surface of the earth
it kind of curves back so that if you
went walking in one direction you
wouldn't hit an edge you'd rather
ultimately return to your starting point
now in terms of what made Einstein so
special
I wish I knew because I would take some
of whatever he was taking because he was
able to see so much further than anybody
else and if you posit a guess as to why
it's because he had this childlike
questionning character
that we see in three four five year olds
but he didn't lose it as he grew older
he was willing to ask those seemingly
simple-minded questions take them very
seriously and he had the intellectual
capacity to see beyond where anybody had
previously seen and come to new ways of
thinking about the universe so roughly
speaking that is how he lived he was a
questioning man and he would not give up
on a question until he found the answer
a single mindedness in the mind of a
genius is something very very powerful
do you have another book on the way I'm
thinking about it but nothing that I'm
writing right now well if for our
viewers if we've whetted your appetite
this is Brian Greene's latest book it's
called the fabric of the cosmos space
time and the texture of reality mr.
Greene's previous book was called the
elegant universe Brian Greene thanks for
joining us today thank you and that
concludes our live programming from the
Chicago Tribune printers row book fair
for today we will be back tomorrow we
will be beginning at 12:30 Eastern Time
that's 11:30 Central Time and you will
see such people as Richard Parker
talking about John Kenneth Galbraith Ted
Fishman talking about China top people
talking about oral histories of Chicago
immigrants genic conan has in the
biography of Robert Oppenheimer and
Michael Lin will be talking about what
Lincoln believed as a value of
convictions of America's greatest
president we'll also be taking phone
calls for a lot of hour for a lot of our
authors so we invite you to join us then
thanks for joining us you've been
watching book TV's live coverage of the
Chicago Tribune printers row book there
[Music]